[Music]
my mom is significantly older than me
and and she always says she's like this
is just one of those things that in my
lifetime I just never thought I see the
city of South Fulton Municipal Court is
the only court system in the entire
country that's run entirely by ask
American women the city of South Fulton
is Georgia's newest city it started in
2017 we became a city with a large
african-american population one of the
largest in the country it is a city that
is made up of urban rural and suburban
communities and I truly think this is
one of the best little places in America
the mayor appointed me first and then I
know you need a solicitor in a public
defender then I had to go about
selecting a court administrator she
along with myself hire the rest of the
staff so that's kind of how it came
about I had the first realization of the
specialness of our court and the first
response that I had was like that black
girl magic
[Music]
alright if you have any selfies with
yourself on Oh oftentimes particularly
for african-americans people feel
railroaded by the system Municipal Court
is often people's first interaction with
the judicial system so it's my position
that we have to get it right because we
can change the perception of the system
if they have a personal experience
that's counter to that counter to what
they perceive in what they've heard and
so you know in South Fulton we're not
gonna be light on crime but we're gonna
make sure that your rights are protected
I'm sorry hold on now you want me to
hear you so you got a raise your voice
up so that I can hear you we believe in
being a model for what a municipal court
and a progressive City looks like all
rise the city of South fourth Municipal
Court is now in session
honourable Tiffany Cara sells the jurors
ID one of the things I think makes our
court particularly unique is how we
treat people we try to take our time and
educate people so when they pre try a
case with me or they're present before
the judge they really get information
about why they are pleading guilty we're
not just saying go do community service
which then do community service within
our community trial was your opportunity
to speak with me about your case and
come to a resolution the law does not
require that the person is appointed a
public defender for their first
appearance hearing I mean in 2018 in a
civilized society we just can do it
better and so the City Council has been
very gracious and providing the funding
necessary to be able to have our public
defenders available whenever someone is
arrested for this force appearance
counts particularly a municipal course
is uncommon and so the dynamic is
absolutely different this was my
opportunity to operate as a model court
to think that we are kind of the first
to court run completely by
african-american women is really
heartwarming it's a lot of I can't
believe it sticking to us 1 and 18
because I think for centuries
african-american women have just done
some outstanding things I'm glad that
we're leading away and showing people
the excellence that can occur I'm an
eternal optimist particularly when it
comes to the criminal justice system
you
[Music]